K-means or something like k-means for
segmentation.
It has some strengths.
It's very simple to do.
By the way, it's guaranteed to converge.
You can sort of show that.
But it has some distinct challenges.
First of all,
it tends to be very memory-intensive,
because you're keeping
all of your points and
you're shuffling them around in,
in in a, in a membership way.
Perhaps one of the biggest ones,
well actually there's two big ones.
One is here is, you need to tell it K,
you need to tell it how many
points there are how many
clusters there are, a priori.
You can try to discover,
that but K-Means doesn't know
anything about how to do that.
It, it's sensitive to initialization and
outliers.
And in particular,
what it's looking for are nice,
essentially spherical clusters, where
they're spherical in feature space.
That is, it doesn't want any
point to be too far away.
And the problem with that
can be illustrated in,
in a figure that looks like this.
So here is a figure with two clusters
in it this one here and this one there.
Now i've drawn them, or that I should
say they've been drawn in red and
blue to help you think that
they should be separate.
But if you, if you were to look at
that pattern, in just black and white,
you probably would say,
well there's this bent cluster here, and
then there's this bent cluster there.
But of course,
if you were to run K-Means,
you would get what's shown here.
This would be one cluster, and
that would be another cluster because
K-Means is looking for
these spherical clusters.